foreign
[Music]
thanks so much for coming today's event
I'm Cooper Weatherby NBA class of 2023
and a student leader of the corporations
and Society initiative or Cassie for
short
Cassie is a faculty initiative here at
The Graduate School of Business that
engages with students and visiting
experts on issues at the intersection of
markets business government and Society
to promote more accountable capitalism
and governance
oftentimes Business Schools promote a
sort of self-serving mythology that
everything can be a win-win that what is
profitable is also by definition good
for society
one of the reasons Cassie exists is to
challenge that notion to start
conversations on campus about the very
real and consequential trade-offs that
exist both in business and in government
between doing what is profitable what is
easy what is popular and what is right
I expect that today's event will address
those themes directly and I'm looking
forward to the conversation between
Bethany Bethany McLean Tark fancy and of
course all of you during our open q a
session later on with that I'll hand
things over to Cassie founder and
faculty director and not admari to
introduce today's guests anat is the
George G C Parker professor of finance
and economics at the GSB and has
researched and written extensively on
the topics of financial markets banking
regulation and corporate governance
she's responsible for arranging much of
the great programming here that falls
under the Cassie umbrella including
today's wonderful event so not take it
away
[Applause]
thank you Cooper Cassie lives by our
awesome student leaders and energized by
it that keeps me going so welcome
everybody I am really happy to see uh
those of you here and many of you on
Zoom the title of this event uh has like
a little equation with a question mark
and it says CSR plus ESG equals BS
question mark I assume you know the BS
part what that means uh but uh what CSR
and ESG is you know
especially CSR you may not know because
CSR goes back to the 60s and 70s where
the debate was called was about
Corporate social responsibility and this
is what Milton Friedman in a very famous
essay in 1970 where he argued that you
know the social responsibility of
Corporations to make as much money as
possible
really ridiculed uh this pontificating
CEOs that speak of CSR Corporate social
responsibility who he said will bring
back the government the Aaron fist of
government bureaucrats who are going to
destroy our free markets that's the way
he respond reacted to these people who
speak about corporate social
responsibility
so that article had a big impact since
1970 the especially people took away
from it corporations to just make money
and live alone anything else which we
may even agree with under some
conditions the debate intensified in
these days people worry about
all kinds of things climate change
inequality diversity you know attitudes
to gender attitudes to race
um and the political
polarization so people worry about these
things and the latest uh sort of
buzzwords are stakeholder capitalism and
ESG and ESG stands for environmental
social governance that's what it stands
for now what it means
wouldn't talk about it you may have
heard that 181 CEOs of top U.S companies
made a statement in 2019 saying that no
no they don't no longer just care about
shareholders which is what they said in
the 70s they now care about the
customers and the employees and the
suppliers and the community uh so
they're good they made that statement
and then
you may have heard also that we have a
lot of ESG investment and ESG ratings
and and ESG actions by corporations and
disclosures and all kinds of debates
about that but then as a debate
intensified it became very political so
then what happened was you know
BlackRock CEO the company that our
guests worked at Larry Fink said
corporations should do good should take
care of society etc etc and now there's
a backlash now some State Governors and
treasurers are taking money out of
BlackRock now they're saying that you
know Banks discriminate against fossil
fuel and they're gonna not do business
with them all these backlash against
woke capitalism another word in the
jargon of this uh debate woke capitalism
so you got these forces so this is all
super confusing
and so uh
the questions are what should be the
roles of corporations in society what
should be the balance of power between
corporations and governments uh who in
the world should take care of us and how
do they do this given what they can do
their powers and their incentives
whether they are politicians or
executives
so whether you're new to this debate or
you have some position or on it already
uh what we have today is a conversation
that will help us move this discussion
forward which is what we at Cassie want
to do
I will um I'm discussing this by the way
I'll plot my own courses in all my
classes to MBA audiences and and others
I'm not teaching the undergrad audience
this year but I will in the future if
you're undergrad uh and both of these
speakers visited my classes now Bethany
actually comes to all the accounting
classes so anybody here in the MBA
program already knows who Bethany McLean
is but for the others I'll introduce
Bethany McLean is an award-winning
investigative journalist and authors she
started career as an investment banking
Analyst at Goldman Sachs before joining
Fortune later Vanity Fair is a
contributor
she's known for writing became famous
over her coverage of Enron starting with
the understatement is Enron overpriced
and then to a book called the smartest
guys in the room which was also made
into a movie and
um and later a book about the financial
crisis and she has a book forthcoming
that I'm sure we'll hear about about the
handling of the pandemic
um
and she's been here already and visited
Cassie event she's a great friend of
Cassie she just moderated one with uh
jatraikova by corporate fraud just a
year ago and so I and she'll introduce
our other our main guest today to Rick
fancy she also has by the ways
associated with the sister organization
in booth called the Stigler Center where
she has a podcast called capitalism so
I'll do a little push of that
um anyway
um I'm thanking Tariq fancy who uh
braved the travel walls of today to make
it here after a long day yesterday and
to Bethany who uh dared to leave Chicago
in the winter again and come to
California in the winter she seems to
somehow agree to that easily anyway I'm
going to let Bethany take it from here
and thank you all for coming
thank you all for being here so I first
want to introduce Our Guest tarek you
were the chief officer for sustainable
investing at BlackRock and we're going
to come back to this later the founder
of an educational company company called
the roomy initiative and you've emerged
as a really prominent critic not a vsg
per se but rather of the very trendy
notion of vsg mechanism ESG investing is
a mechanism for Change and so I think
our goal in this conversation is for you
to help us figure out the nuances of a
topic that seems really simple on the
surface isn't it the right thing for all
of us to put our money into things that
Advance the social and environmental
goals that we want to see but it's
actually anything but
so going to anat's comments I wanted to
start at the very beginning ESG
sustainable investing impact investing
responsible investing ethical investing
what do these terms mean and do any of
them actually mean anything at all
um so first of all thanks for having me
um it's real pleasure to be here to
speak
and ESG I mean the best way to think
about it is sort of to start with what
the financial services industry says it
is right so generally speaking it means
taking the art of investing in finance
and overlaying a set of additional
considerations environmental social and
governance by which they mean corporate
governance considerations over that
investing style and it allows an asset
manager to do two things primarily so
number one you have a bunch of existing
investment activities if you're black
Rockets 10 trillion or whatever it is
and now you can create a new category of
vehicles green products that purport to
do something in addition to gaining a
market return right to create some
special green benefit or whatever so in
a sense from Financial perspective
they're kind of like if you go to
Walmart and you have the green detergent
next to the regular detergent or some
green pre premium price sustainability I
think it's kind of like that for the
financial service industry so that's
number one and that new category is very
popular for the industry because it
means new assets and growth and they
usually almost always have premium
prices attached right so the average ESG
fund is 41 higher fees than non-esg
funds so that's that's there the second
thing ESG means is not a product a new
product as much as a process enhancement
so what they say is okay well here's the
existing stuff we were doing from before
that's not new that whatever trillion or
whatever it is and uh we're going to
Overlay ESG considerations onto that and
that means looking at another data set
to help you invest and the premise is
always held by the industry that ESG
data is really really useful for us to
invest with because better ESG
performance means better returns which
is financial jargon for saying
responsible companies or good companies
right which is a higher ESG score in
theory is what's been implied they're
also more profitable
and so to translate what that means I
would think about capitalism as a sport
right it's a competition so I I
personally am a big soccer fan but I use
basketball because I think North
Americans need to hear this more than
Europeans a little by a notch
um so let's imagine we're comparing it
to basketball uh on the court you're a
player and you have to focus on scoring
against one scoreboard right points and
you only win point you know the game is
won or lost on points it's no good
sportsmanship category that you know it
can play into the game but the final
determine is the points capitalism is
similar to competition but the bottom
line is profits and what's important is
that the players are locked into going
for profit so I can get into that in a
minute but anyways ESG the idea is that
good sportsmanship leads to square more
points right that we live in a world
that rewards that and it's a win-win
there's a lot in there to discuss I had
another question for you and I think
you've provided part of the answer for
it with your observation that ESG
products carry far heavier fees but
there's this number predicted by
Bloomberg intelligence that more than
one-third of all globally managed assets
could carry explicitly ESG labels by
2025 amounting to more than 50 trillion
why has ESG investing become such a hot
fad on Wall Street or have we already
covered that yeah I mean so first of all
we have to start with those numbers
they're just completely ludicrous and
they're ludicrous for a few reasons
first of all I mean having seen on the
inside it's kind of generally known that
there's no concrete
um
definition on what that is because it's
hard to Define these things right ESG in
general I mean the E things are fairly
quantifiable but the S get very
difficult and are hard to measure it's
very very subjective
and so when they usually put these
labels on funds
there's really no rigor around it or no
clear body that's been in charge and so
a lot of it's just box ticking and
there's an important reason why it's box
ticking it's because they legally can't
say that we're going to look at ESG
always and do the better thing because
it would be a violation of fiduciary
duty so fiduciary duty is this law that
basically says if you're managing
someone else's assets you have to focus
on maximizing the value of those and
some I'm simplifying but and the idea is
that that's measured in value not values
right because everybody has different
values right I'll joke if you if you're
in Europe and you go to France nuclear
is great then you go to Germany nuclear
is the worst
but value is objective right and and so
they have to think about value in terms
and and dollars so so they really can't
do these things and there's just
different variations of like these sort
of sustainable labels and obviously the
worst of these massive numbers that
effectively mean nothing like they're I
mean one way of looking is if you graph
the growth in ESG and green assets they
go up alongside carbon emissions and
inequality over the last 10 years like
exactly the things they're meant to do
something about and the problem is
multi-fold number one there's no
definition any of that so it's just
non-binding marketing pledges that we
will consider ESG while we invest but
you can so you're definitely going to do
it because you'd be violating fiduciary
duty and not to mention their incentives
of the people making decisions are also
aligned you know in terms of higher
return
so in general the you know the problem
with those sorts of Statistics don't
really mean anything right and so at
some point if all you're doing is
putting green paint on an existing
system
um the argument uh starts to turn from
isn't this harmless right because hey
how can green investing be worse than
like what we're already doing to is this
becoming a dangerous Placebo where or
what I call a convenient fantasy to
address An Inconvenient Truth that
allows us to believe that we can keep
everything the same and not incur any
sacrifice or from an economics
perspective taxes and regulation right
which are the actual expert and Nobel
prize winning sort of ideas on how to
address this and you know just have more
ESG stuff lots of ESG firms and they're
rating them and then better performers
do better and make more money and then
the system corrects itself without us
needing to change the rules in any way
before we come back to that idea that it
is a convenient fiction a dangerous
Placebo let's let's go back to you a
little bit how did you first get
involved with questions of
sustainability and how did you see these
ideas start to impact the mainstream
investing world and what was the
beginning of your your skepticism or
going to call it skepticism not cynicism
okay good absolutely so um the
skepticism comes from a from a real
place which is that my background was
that I I um I wanted to do something in
Academia I missed out on a scholarship
in the final round of undergrad I grew
up in Toronto with school in the states
and then uh ended up doing Banking and
actually ended up down the street I was
here in Palo Alto doing Tech banking for
a guy called Frank cuatron
um at the tail end of the.com bubble
that led to me eventually going back to
New York and being hired by a client who
was a distressed or a vulture investment
firm and so my old boss had been the
chief investment officer for a guy
called Carl Icahn
um uh and you know but so it's very
aggressive sharp elbow inside of Finance
very very skeptical borderline cynical
but it's because you go into situations
where management teams are likely to lie
to you because it's a distressed
situation right so no matter how bad the
company's going it's like you're always
the bottom of a hockey stick when you
meet them right because it's not going
to show you continuing to Glide so bit
skeptical
um I left sometime after did grad school
and then ended up doing roomie which is
a non-profit and it brought me back here
actually because it was a non-profit we
went through Y combinator and um you
know the whole thing is really using a
smartphone as a learning tool
and having left the industry and having
kind of been on the extremes of purpose
and profit uh that's kind of how the
role found me that BlackRock was kind of
leaning into and a lot of financial
firms leaning into this area because
they saw growth potential and so anyway
they they created new rules Chief
investment officer for sustainable
investors and were they leaning into it
do you think because they saw a growth
potential
potential because they saw that because
they really believed that it that it
could change the world or because they
saw it as a way to keep the status quo
well while enabling us all to believe
that we were doing our part to change
things
so uh you ask a really interesting
question because as a next Insider it
doesn't it wouldn't be fair for me to
say that I think people know that
they're doing that because I don't I
actually think that if I could drink the
Kool-Aid it would be ludicrous of me to
then throw it on other people and say
well other people have married Kool-Aid
so you know I don't cast aspersions on
anyone inside the system I think a lot
of people are sort of siled
um and and or they don't have
necessarily the requisite skill set
because being a distressed person you
are the good at one thing above all else
that pretty much drives how the
financial industry actually works is
that you can read incentives and if you
don't change incentives then you're not
going to change the behavior of the
system right and it's the centers are
misaligned and one of the problems about
ESG is for all of its Bluster it doesn't
actually do the one thing that changes
uh the industry would change then in
fact it distracts us from the fact that
we're not
um
uh yeah sorry did that answer it it did
so let's go back to something you
touched on earlier which is this idea of
profit and purpose can there be an
overlap is there a Venn diagram in which
there is an overlapping area or do you
think the two always have to be separate
and how do you think about all the
competing numbers out there about ESG I
mean the claims from the industry that
it does lead to better returns Paul
Tudor Jones famously launched his firm
uh five years ago saying ESG does lead
to better returns but then there are
other pieces including a recent study
saying no no it doesn't and so do you
think there's an overlap or do you think
believing that there is an overlap is
inherently dangerous and how do you sort
through all the conflicting numbers so
first of all most of these a lot of
these studies are really dubious they're
done by people who are self-interested
to believe that that's one of the things
I wrote about in that this one paper I
wrote that went viral called The Secret
Diary of a sustainable investor it was a
four-part or three parts and I added an
epilogue but you know the idea was that
a lot of people want to believe this and
so on some level I think in Academia
there is a very innocent desire to be
seen to like be providing encouraging
signals to business that if you do this
little ESG thing like you'll do better
in the world's a better place and it
comes from a good place of wanting to
encourage them to do that uh having been
inside the system again when I look at
how the money moves
I think ultimately the only question we
have around especially the environmental
issues is one of are we going to rely on
voluntary compliance or mandatory
compliance and I actually look at a
massive value transfer going across
different groups in society around that
and I look at some of these ESG studies
that are based on bankrupt data and you
know first of all it's so hard to
measure ESG that you can make the data
say whatever you want because you can
regress returns or whatever you want
against a moving Target right and having
published academic research myself and
I'm not an economist that was cited in
the Canadian federal budget I can
honestly tell you that like you can kind
of torture the numbers to make it say
things that you wanted you know so the
conclusion has to have common sense and
so the problem with a lot of these
studies is they seem to be intended to
serve that goal I don't know if people
are intentionally necessarily doing that
but through the system of incentives and
power kind of comes out that the people
say it as not a countervailing voice in
the system because like if you say ESG
is good for returns and purpose and
profit overlap like you get a lot of
Consulting work companies if you go and
say you need regulation
like who's who's gonna like who's paying
you to say that you know what I mean
like the government's not hiring you on
a contract so the incentives are move in
One Direction and so it is difficult to
make sense of of any of that stuff and
my concern has been that if you
if you look at it some of what business
seems to be doing looks like the tobacco
industry in the 50s right so I'm a
capitalist but I think it's important to
distinguish between two types of
capitalism Tesla capitalism and tobacco
capitalism Tesla capitalism is we need
more EVs and we need them fast so you
can shake up the industry and create
stuff people need and move in that
direction that's great by the way
government has a role to play there
right government can actually go in and
push more of that and the best example
of that is think of how we produce a
vaccine in record time well I don't like
they just sat around right operation War
speed had billions of dollars in direct
funding and r d to companies a billion
vaccine pre-orders you know expedited
approval process so government can push
Tesla capitalism more
and then there's tobacco capitalism
tobacco capitalism is you know uh I have
a Profit Stream of a hundred dollars
that is at risk of Regulation right
regulating the sale of minors all kinds
of things that happen in the 50s when we
realized that smoking causes cancer or
started to realize and so if you have a
hundred dollars of a Profit Stream and
you realize that you could protect it
with twenty dollars of marketing 15
bucks of lobbying technically that's
what you should do
and and and no one wants to go out and
say that in business even though that's
what fiduciary duty generally means is
that you know unless you can create an
argument that you know that'll come back
and haunt you or you know some PR risk
or this that and the other but it has to
be internalized by Society right that
externality unless you know uh if the
government isn't doing it
and so
um and so what you see is tobacco
companies you know they put out of
something in 1956 called the Franc
statement to cigarette smokers and it
said you know of Paramount importance to
us is the you know is the is the health
of our customers and oh by the way
here's some you know maybe smoking
doesn't cause cancer like here's some
other evidence right and
all we know that we know what that was
about that was basically about them
protecting their prop stream as long as
they could a study at Yale showed that
eight million American lives were saved
because of the regulation of tobacco
right eight times the coveted pandemic
now it's 2019 right let's go back to a
few years ago and
coming out of the financial crisis seems
to be an inadequate amount of the one
thing that we probably all wanted which
was some level of Regulation to fix the
system it doesn't believe like all the
themes of God out of the system is trust
which has unfortunately found its way
into weird cryptocurrencies and other
things right they're justifying them but
there doesn't seem to be as much of
Regulation and let's be honest obviously
that's in part because after 2010 and
the citizens united Supreme Court
decision the players on the court have
an unlimited ability to recycle their
potentially ill glad gains into
protecting those loopholes so of course
they do that right through the system of
lobbying and parents nothing and so uh
2019 The Business Roundtable then comes
out with something called uh you know
um was it stakeholder stakeholders
stakeholder capitalism statement and it
basically is the effective it's the
equivalent of like the good
sportsmanship pledge right and it's like
we're going to do a lot of good stuff
for people and if it's in our interests
and it's new way of doing business and
they pretend to depart from the Milton
Friedman view of the world which is this
economy who said that like just focus on
profits and um and in the end you know
the two law professors Harvard Law
School did a study and they found that
98 of the boards that signed that thing
had not ratified it with their own board
of directors which means it has no legal
meaning because you're registered in
Delaware and there's a very clear
set of laws that you have to focus on
shareholders the end I mean it was a PR
statement and like at some point you
look at that and you think is that being
responsible right one more stat sorry I
keep blathering on but this is an
amazing one from last summer uh they
surveyed in fact that 58 of the c-suite
believe that their own companies are
guilty of greenwashing
wow that's zero percent of the pr teams
are saying that by the way in the U.S
and did I take it that was an anonymous
survey I don't know definitely not on
the surface Google Harris Cloud if you
if you Google it it's amazing the base
the best part is America since it was it
was uh 68 percent
it's like two-thirds so it's like at
some point they kind of know that their
incentives are misaligned with the
public interest like the greatest
example that by the way is Larry Fink my
old boss CEO BlackRock is a founding
member of something called focusing on
capital for the long term and it's an
initiative that comes out of the fact
that all this research shows that
capitalism becomes too short-term
oriented right yes CEO pays the highest
it's been a decades 320 times the
average industry worker the 10 years
shortest being decades you know five
years and so they don't really care
about the long term it's not in their
you know incentive that's why you see
they see a slow-moving systemic curve we
need to flatten greenhouse gas emissions
they're like maybe the free market will
solve that even though it's obviously a
market failure
um and then along comes with fast moving
systemic curve that we need to flatten
it's covid and the incubation period is
not a few decades a few weeks and
they're all suddenly like call the
government and they all support the
Business Roundtable actually looked at
supported not just we should wear masks
but there should be mandatory mask
mandates right there's like I mean you
know we should restrict travel all the
things the government did right which
number one it's flat in the curve in one
hand using you know this is not
neoliberalism this is like the hand the
government comes in right and then on
the other hand you Galvanize the private
sector to find solutions that was
Operation warp speed
we've sort of done the second one but
it's with a lot of carrots and not a lot
of sticks and it's like because it's
impossible seems to raise taxes and so a
lot the inflation reduction act seems to
be setting off an arms race with Europe
in terms of subsidies but generally it
helps but we haven't done that we
haven't done really nearly as much on
Curbing business
um especially around the eat issues so I
loved your comment about torturing the
numbers as a former math major I'm
really good at torturing the numbers and
learning how much they could be tortured
has been part of my education in the
business world but is what you're saying
and essentially that capitalism can be
either about changing the Status Quo or
it can be about protecting the status
quo and that some of the incentives even
the legal requirements for corporations
to maximize profits are essentially
protecting the status quo
that's pretty much that's pretty much it
I think I mean I think that you know it
can be used to Galvanize a better status
quo in terms of like there's no question
in my mind that capitalism is the best
system to if used correctly to pull out
the Innovations we need and they're so
much harder than what people make them
out to be for net zero right in terms of
like actually you know if you look at
food production all these other things
of how fossil fuels plan it's extremely
difficult so I think we can get
Solutions if we direct capitalism
effectively but we also need to be
honest about the ones that are not in
our interests where it's the tobacco
capitalism and my biggest concern is
that the leaders of the system today
don't seem to actually understand the
difference or feel that there's some
obligation to show real leadership in
the 2020s and say that there's a
difference right and and there's it's
it's it's not unimportant if they if so
one of the things I found really
interesting was that because of the
other thing I do roomies really gen Z
users a lot of young people hits
underserved communities and
um I did a session with them once
because I'm still a board chair they're
uh of
um you know to talk to them about sort
of the stuff we're doing and um and they
basically you could sort of see amongst
young people and in the data they don't
believe in capitalism anymore and it's
one of the things I worry about a little
bit is that you know if uh if that
continues too long and creates political
instability yeah
you
and who wrote a book essentially arguing
that a lot of what a lot of what our
leaders do as Charity is actually a way
of keeping the status quo as it is and
preventing change rather than
encouraging change and it seems to me
that your argument about ESG investing
is of a piece with that intellectually
that a lot of it is about keeping the
status quo rather than actually changing
the Status Quo does that sound fair yep
yeah
I'd say I think the one difference
between myself and him is probably that
he's a journalist and I'm an ex-insider
and I'm and you know
I tend to be pretty skeptical and
cynical I would say if I honestly
thought people were in the middle of the
system like trying to screw us smoking
cigars in a room that's not what it is
the end of the day the system you know
power will have a greater voice and
conversation whether it's Dabo so here
or there it'll Bend towards where people
have interest right
um you know the public policy will try
to slow tax Rises and regulation the ESG
team will paint whatever they're doing
green right which is like you know it's
like a fruits in the grocery store 30
years ago if No One Believes what it is
to be organic you'll all put the sticker
on right so everyone's saying they're
doing it and yet nothing actually is and
I think
um you know in that in that um in that
context I think
um you know you almost need to sort of
sort of figure out a way but get money
out of politics and sort of unlock the
different mechanisms of of changing it
before we come back to government action
I wanted to pause on another potential
solution and have you tell me why it's
not a solution okay so part of the
problem is that corporate law requires
companies to put shareholders interests
first and investors are required to put
fiduciary duty first why can't we just
change those laws and Why can't your
investment products and your in
companies carry an explicit disclaimer
we're not putting these things first
we're putting other things first why
wouldn't that be a way to solve these
issues uh so it sounds like an alluring
idea of practice it means like changing
fiduciary duty to sort of be like okay
now you cannot consider other stuff
there's one reason it won't work it's
that everybody has different values and
I don't really want my banker
redesigning Society you know what I mean
it's like oh like that would basically
be saying that like the Larry Finks of
the world
um hey we're going to give you the tools
to decide like what's Society how we
should make Society better and there is
one point where the Republican pushback
uh on against CSG is right is that
they're saying look you don't have a
democratic right to make that argument
right like no one elected Larry Fink
where they don't
where they don't continue to argue Farm
enough is that to really hand the keys
back to people who respond to the public
you'd also need to get money out of
politics I would say yeah so let's dig
let's dig before we come back to this
idea of mandatory government action
there is some commonality as you just
mentioned between you and one of the
most prominent critics of ESG from the
other end of the spectrum Vivek Ram the
swathi who wrote a book called woke Inc
arguing basically that corporations have
no place in advancing any kind of
environmental social or government
governance goal where do you two meet
and where do you think you you again
have intellectual commonality and where
do you think you differ so where we
differ or I just mentioned probably most
of all he makes the argument that um
that the government has a democratic
right because you've been elected and so
don't lose some fiduciary do to keep it
tight and the government should use
regulations to change behavior for
example you know mandatory restrictions
or taxes on carbon whatever it is
um and so I think unless you get money
out of politics he's got half the
argument right but then the other half
doesn't make any sense which given to be
back by Peter Thiel and a bunch of like
libertarian types who don't seem to want
regulation it doesn't surprise me all
that much like for the same reason that
when I went out there and wrote The
Secret Diary sustainable that's right I
never use the word democrat or
republican because I don't think it's my
role to really go in and I just want to
make our agreements without landmines
that that people will fall into
and the Wall Street Journal loved loved
half my argument I said yes she doesn't
work we need regulation they love the
first the second they forgot about it
seems
um and so on that point I think Vivek
and I are different but I do think he
makes a lot of interesting and very good
points around the fact that Business
Leaders are pretending to show
leadership and actually almost cowardly
at times and the point he talks about
how Business Leaders will say here will
be ready to throw themselves behind the
latest fashionable cause and it doesn't
seem to be really based on conviction
more than it is sort of a convenient PR
strategy and yet in China they won't say
a thing yep and he's he's absolutely
right it's weakened American leadership
and it's an example for me of where
American capitalism is getting in the
way of American democracy at exactly the
worst time in history for that to happen
why do you say that why do you say the
I think for a whole bunch of reasons
that we probably won't be able to get
into today you know whether it's
um uh you know trends of reverse and
globalization of rising inequality the
backlash against globalization because
we only did half the deal right because
globalization has expands the pie but
it's going to rapidly redistribute the
pieces and so you need worker retraining
and all kinds of other things the first
part happened the second didn't in part
because it didn't seem like you could
even raise taxes or really
um you know so just it just massively
increase inequality you look at all
those things at a time of extreme
political polarization right
um of which of course you know startup
cable media and then it's been
supercharged by algorithms I think it
you know democracy is under threat like
never before everyone kind of knows that
and there's a strong authoritarian model
I think it's it's easy for us to take
for granted in the west that a lot of
the world doesn't agree with the NATO
position on Ukraine and Russia and other
things and this this seems to me like
the worst time for Business Leaders to
you know to be recorded in history like
this is these are all digital traces
right I mean I look at it and I'm like
like why are you putting your name on a
building like at this point like you're
just renting that space for 10 or 15
years because we all know the science is
real and there's digital traces of
everything right now so like you know at
some point we have to almost pull the
moral cloak of responsibility away and I
think one thing where Vivek is right it
probably is that and we're shared is it
like
you know you don't get the moral cloak
of respectability if all you're doing is
running a cheap PR strategy that's going
to switch whenever it's convenient and
that we've seen that happen a bunch of
times and maybe there's another Point
here that that is maybe there's another
Point here about the undermining of
trust that everyone is smart enough to
be able to say wait does Nate you're
doing this in order to defend rights in
Florida but yet you're also doing this
in China that is an undermining of Human
Rights and that all of that undermines
faith and democracy and Trust in
democracy and that's a huge problem at
this point in time I'd say so I mean I
think the best example I can tell you
the position of Business Leaders is to
use the the Draymond Green Theory which
I I came up with earlier today so I'm
going to start with the basketball
analogy so imagine basketball's gone
really dirty and everyone decides we've
got to clean up the game right and then
there's a press conference afterwards
and Draymond Green comes out and he
starts listing all the stuff that like
people are doing for you know to they're
doing the big play clean and whatever
and you know like we have this new coach
you teach display clean blah blah you
know one of the random stuff we went to
this Hospital on Sunday all the stuff
and suddenly one of the journal says hey
by the way Draymond we heard a rumor
that you may be making secret payments
to the refs behind the scenes do you
mind talking about that and then
Draymond just said nah and he left like
how many people on this like how many
people do you think how many people here
think that uh we should believe Draymond
and he actually wants to clean up the
game
I I suspect it would be zero okay so
right now four American companies Boeing
Netflix Disney and BlackRock all four of
them eagerly put out CS CSR things ESG
things whatever non-standard act for the
most part takes this kind of stuff
they're doing things a little bit more
green put it out there I'm sure some of
it's real but it's like mostly just
marketing and PR
all four of those companies in recent
years faced shareholder resolutions from
their own shareholders asking them to
disclose their political spending which
as we know in the post citizens united
era is otherwise we wouldn't know what
it is it's traceless limos all four of
those companies fought off those
shareholder resolutions I mean how can
that be the position of business or
experts in society we listen to them on
the epidemiologists on how to flatten
the curve right infectious disease
people said here's out spreads than the
epidemiology said well this is a human
behavior question so you got to close
the schools like you can't leave the
Sports bar open the night of the big
game and expect you know when there's no
vaccine that you're going to like stop
the spread right we had to be honest
about it and now Business Leaders are in
a position where climate scientists have
told us that you know and all around
this biodiversity sustainability that
we're going to need regulations we're
going to need to start making changes
um and their corollary is going to be
Economist and the economists are same as
a human behavior question like Bill
nordhaus the guy who talks about carbon
tax actually has a line where he says
look there's trillions of of
transactions billions of people informed
and millions of you know different
players in the system there's no way you
can do that without a systemic solution
and
um and Business Leaders in a position of
basically preventing a lot of those
behind the scenes through lobbying and
spending it destroys the actual soul of
capitalism and it destroys the
foundation of the system
kids of history that have undermined
trust and government and trust in
business is now higher than it's ever
been at least according to this recent
study perhaps self-interested by by
Edelman but in order to advance the
solution that you think is important
which is which is government action that
requires the very trust in government
that's that's lacking so how do we how
do we how do we resolve that conundrum I
think I mean I think the biggest
question we should ask is to Business
Leaders how are you going to help how
are you going to fix the government
because the week I started is this week
or the second week I started beginning
of 2018 Larry Fink writes this letter
where he talks where it makes this big
splash all over the world and if you
know in the corners of Davos and
whatever and entity says the company
should have a social purpose right and
it got all this attention
but it's the way he said it he said
specifically the government is failing
on a set of issues that are clearly of
importance to the public interest
whether building infrastructure
retirement savings or sustainability or
whatever else and he said therefore
Business Leaders should step in with
social purpose
clearly they don't have the incentives
to do that right and it's very clear
they have no answer to anything that
people like myself has to push back on
they just ran off the pr stage and you
know and I say like it's impossible to
show the world the emperor has no
clothes if he locks himself in the
bathroom and doesn't come out and I
think the real question we should ask
them is that listen like this is
democracy 101 like you can't replace the
role of elected politicians even Milton
Friedman said that he said it would be
intolerable on political principle of
them to do that so I think the question
for Business Leaders is how are you
going to fix the government how are you
going to fix democracy at a time and
that has to start for me with looking at
political spending like I don't care
like how can a company hide their
political spending and not get an
automatic zero ESG score like it's
that's an instant red card for me right
and I think it's just dishonest of them
and at this point almost constitutes a
value transfer from the junior employees
Junior more diverse employees to the you
know the richest people at the top
because the system is so short-term
oriented we're squeezing out value at
the public interest someone's going to
pay for that I was thinking when you
were talking
um there's a great quote from kmu that
fiction is the lie that tells the truth
and I'm not sure if anybody in the room
has read the book Cloud Atlas but it's
essentially a dystopian World in which
corporations are have have become much
government no longer exists it's all
corporations and sometimes I wonder if
governments of Corporations actually
want that world and if they want to fix
government I'm going to ask one more
question and while we we do that answer
if you all want to start lining up to
ask whatever questions you might have uh
that would be that would be great but I
wanted to get it one fundamental
objection to what you're saying might be
but rules we don't we don't want rules
for our free market the great glory of
the free market why should why should we
be restrained by any rules and won't
that be inhibit the functioning of the
free market what would you say in
response to that yeah it's crazy I mean
the greatest hoax is the free market
hoax right like ask any ask any lawyer a
market is just a collection of rules you
can change those rules and you'll get
different outcomes all of which would be
be considered Market outcomes and I
think those those rules are deliberate
right so it doesn't make any sense to
say that the government's intervening in
the free market any more than they would
say that like the NBA is intervening in
the game of basketball by drawing a line
behind which you get three points for a
shot they can move that line back if
they want less three-pointers like those
are all deliberate rules that create
outcomes of the system and I think
um you know this reflexive
anti-regulation
push has to be replaced by a more
intelligent understanding of the fact
that systemic Solutions are going to
require the power of government because
it has powers to make things mandatory
rather than voluntary and to make them
systemic across all quarters which we
don't see even the financial Market
stuff moves from public to private hands
it just bounces around because people
are getting paper profits on reducing
emissions and so I think yeah it's a
combination of of of of of uh of things
probably
so while we wait to see if there are any
questions from the audience Cooper are
there any from zoom and why don't we go
to the zoom Channel first and I'm going
to have Cooper step up and read those
yeah thanks Bethany
um one so a couple questions from our
virtual attendees here
um first question here if the work of
ESG analysts and teams has little impact
on the investment decisions and the
asset management companies could it be
assumed that most ESG rhetoric is green
washing whether intentional or
unintentional
that's a good question I think it really
depends on what you say the goal is the
vsg one of the biggest challenges for
the industry is it never actually
clarified whether this is good for
investors or good for the planet right
those are completely different things
and but because of the of the nature of
fiduciary duty as I discussed earlier
they kind of had to say it was good for
returns otherwise you couldn't be doing
it so they said oh it's great for
returns and then it was kind of left
like unclear is it good for the planet
or not and in the end
um it's been doesn't really that much
for return it doesn't a few places but
really only long-term strategies that
are private in the liquid most
strategies it doesn't really unlock any
value it doesn't create any value for
the world for sure in terms of
allocating Capital correctly but it's
definitely a big win for asset managers
that reminds me actually of this
pointed to in some of your writings that
I just was taking place and was done in
the summer of 2020 in which most of the
public mistakenly believes that managing
climate-related Financial risks somehow
fights climate change itself yeah so
what we've found in this study was
number one no one knows what like helps
and doesn't help so when bankers and
Central bankers and finance people go up
and say we're protecting against climate
risks they mean climate risks in their
portfolios not stopping climate change
from happening so the way I explain it
is a friend of mine in Miami was this
actually happened he was looking to buy
a house and it was when I was at
BlackRock and he said oh you know I'm
worried about the long term but he said
oh you guys are so giant you're focused
on climate risks
and he didn't get it until I finally
said listen we're not trying to stop
Miami from getting wrecked by climate
change we're trying to get our money out
before it hits
right that's pretty much what it means
and so from a moral perspective it's
like the answer to the girl in the
village in Bangladesh is like don't
worry our rich clients are not going to
lose any money when your home gets
destroyed like but but people don't know
the difference 80 of people thought
protecting against climate risks and
portfolios meant protecting against
climate change the big challenge is
um is that the average person doesn't
know that like a lot of what's been
pitched in sustainable investing is uh
leverages a lot of ignorance around how
the system works just because the
average person doesn't tend to be that
know these things and be super Financial
literally and the biggest problem with
it is it always and concludes that if I
do the right if I do the right thing and
I stop doing the wrong thing then the
wrong thing will stop happening right so
if I divest of oil players then they're
going to be deprived of capital which
does not happen all you happen is you
sell a share to someone else and because
that was a former vulture investor I
know because we would wait for stuff
like this people would say oh we're
going to sell this thing for completely
non-economic reasons because it's
ethically wrong and all that happens is
you know uh is that it changes hands
let's go to a question oh oh wait go
ahead apologies my name is I'm a DCI
fellow here at Stanford I agree with
what you lay out that we probably need
fundamental change but given that we
have such a short timeline to act upon
climate change don't you see a role in
between like instead of black and white
a gray Zone to actually get more of what
you call the Tesla kind of capitalism
going and what could be the positive
forces in that scenario do you mean of
of the free Mark itself starting to do
that or yeah like you know in the end we
have very little time to act and bring
positive action right you're saying the
role is government and regulation which
yes in an ideal world would be but the
change is so slow to get the government
into that role so is there intermediate
steps we should take right now
uh it's a good question I I think um
I mean they're you know
I guess one thing I'd say start with
when I say government
um I would distinguish between
governance provider and government's
regulator
or a government's provider is actually
building electric vehicles and whatever
that I don't mean that would be like
refs taking three-pointers we don't want
that but someone's got to call the fouls
right and so governments regulator is
actually saying you know you can uh you
know if you pollute we're going to now
find you for that we're going to
subsidize things
I think there's a cultural change that
can get more going with green stuff but
I don't think it's us talking about it
more because
I'm actually concerned that it's been
talked about so much without really
mandatory regulations to back the actual
push that it's creating a massive
Divergence between expectations and
reality and as I said I I think we
ignore that at our Peril right I mean
people also young people don't know
capitalism like I'm 44 of the majority
people younger me don't believe in
capitalism and they say oh they don't
know what capitalism is and I'll be like
yep I didn't know what Trump's policies
were when they voted for them or what
brexit meant when they pressed the reset
button right so all of which is to say I
do think there are things that can be
done
but I think that the free Market's going
to do whatever it's going to or nothing
the market system as currently
structured it's going to do whatever
it's going to do
and it's going to move in the direction
speed has been moving in and we could
remove the green washing and the like
stopping regulation because you know
that that's just dangerous and I think
take some of the tools that have been
built the ingredients around ESG of our
measurement disclosures and used in ways
that actually Force mandatory compliance
like there's a hybrid of solutions that
I think can be done but my concern would
be lionizing the few winners and the
individual success stories because that
tends to be in my experience used to
further the event the idea that we don't
need to do anything so it's like Steph
Curry he's so great he scores all these
points and he's Sportsman like business
hospitals everyone's going to be like
Steph Curry
but I'm like this is a static problem
like we need masks but we also need a
mask mandate which means there's a
Latrell Sprewell and a bunch of players
will punch you in the face over there so
all of which is to say you know my
concern about a lot of the green
marketing is that it actually might have
just made us complacent
really interesting I think a lot about
this idea side storytelling and how
and how behind what you're getting at
the storytelling when they're stories
that are really convenient for us to
believe are can be really really
dangerous anyway to you
yeah hi I'm Nick Hill I'm an NBA one um
you know you ended with the notion in
your remarks about how businesses need
to put effort into fixing government to
change the regulatory framework I think
you'd have probably a lot of allies with
the sentiment in the room like can I
push you on solve so like you were in uh
BlackRock like what would it take to
turn a company like that towards uh
making those kinds of efforts on the
ground so I think you're part of the
solution that's the good news to start
with I'll always tell you if you told me
okay we need to fix government so people
will traditionally think okay we should
go rally the politicians and do stuff I
actually would tell you that I wouldn't
waste time doing that because I think
they're just not they're not going to
move until the Overton window has
shifted first from a place where we have
these convenient win-win crap to like
this is going to take sacrifice and
cause money and I think then there's
room to do it and I'd start with the
business community and that's why I've
tried to start a debate in the business
community and to answer your question I
think to put pushed him do the right
thing I don't think they're worried
about Elizabeth Warren's office calling
them like they have a public policy team
they've been dealing with that for
decades they're going to keep dealing
with that you know what they'll never
have a plan for is if they suddenly get
caught on their flank because all of
their younger employees say wait a
second the question of whether
stakeholder cat like we love stakeholder
capitals we all agree but the real
question is should it be subject to
mandatory compliance or voluntary
compliance and they realize that a
system that's far too short-term
oriented just constitutes a value
transfer because you know Larry thinks
seven years old he gets the mo he gains
the Muslim system leads to the risk of
the consequences of an action his 22
year old entry level employees she's in
the exact opposite situation if
employees the younger employees actually
said wait a second why is our forget the
ESG team why is our public policy team
fighting against binding regulations
that would protect the environment
because we're going to end up eating the
cost of that like we're going to be
around in 2050 like have having our
first kid or whatever I actually think
businesses wouldn't have any answer to
that question because as soon as the
employees start art
moving and rallying the board won't know
what to do because if you lose the
troops the board's saying like they
know how to deal with the you know
Sheldon White House's you know office
right they've been doing that for years
and keep doing that but I do honestly
think that younger employees this is
where I come back to you you're gonna
this is where it all begins I do think
have an outsized voice because they
won't have an answer to that the ESG
stuff is being fed to young people
generally speaking both inside and
outside the system you can sell more to
Millennials if you have the green
detergent you sell a premium price no
one even checks if it's green it's a
pretty good deal
um but um but you know if those people
turn around and say wait a second we
followed the experts on like the
epidemiologist said the newly government
things it clearly hit the economy right
notwithstanding the fact that the
Federal Reserve dislocated the financial
markets separate question but generally
speaking you know it hurt the economy
it's the same players The Business
Roundtable who are behind the scenes
lobbying against flattening the
greenhouse Gasper they don't have an
answer to that question right I mean
that's why there's you can't get it you
can't get a debate out of them right
it's impossible
um to to there's no accountability right
I mean imagine if I left and I worked
for a minister in the government and I
said this is all crap this is stupid it
doesn't even work I wrote this long
paper saying that their argument is
totally incoherent like they would have
to answer the next day
but they don't have to answer now right
it's not part of their PR strategy right
so someone's got to force them to
respond and I don't think it's going to
be Elizabeth Warren's office we might
guess
Cooper do we have another question from
the zoom audience yeah we've actually
got quite a few so I'm gonna just do
kind of a quick speed Round Here For You
tart so first one
um the ESG convergence initiative we
were talking about lack of standardized
ESG metrics Calpers Carlisle
um and others have led 260 private
Equity General partners for a unified
six-part ESG standard and Reporting
framework
um just your thoughts on the
effectiveness of that type of approach
well so obviously
having multiple standards is a disaster
the more that they converge around
certain things and those questions
around material double material
generally the more they're standardized
the better because they can be useful
for something I would stress this is
very important just to finish that
answer that there's a big difference
between measuring something and managing
it right so if you just have disclosure
that's like VAR
without a referee to give out a red card
like when you see the tackle in slow
motion but like you still need a penalty
so they have to be done in concert
awesome next one uh you use the term
responsibility as the key what would be
key elements of a corporate political
responsibility movement Beyond
disclosure of spending I think to defend
democracy
by doing everything in your power to
make it succeed not supporting the
polarization of the population not
supporting the regulatory capture by
special interests not avoiding
accountability about these issues by
going to Davos which curiously has you
know not many panels on tax increases
and stuff like that like I get that
these are not convenient for them but to
pretend that these debates don't need to
happen is a heist that's being committed
against younger or poorer darker skinned
people like it's not missed on me that
Larry Fink is older richer and whiter
than I am and it's the groups I
represent that are losing out from this
stalling right so anyway hopefully that
answers
it's great the last one here um
just a question about the recent
movement toward B Corps and other uh
firms with social impact embedded in
their core businesses and often in their
governance documents and whether you
think that's an effective approach to
address some of these social ills and
needs
it's not harmful but the idea that that
is the solution is in and of itself
they're helpful but the idea that that's
the solution is extremely dangerous
right because remember in the post-world
War II period there are better outcomes
in terms of economic inequality in this
country and better outcomes in terms of
the Environmental Protection by the way
Richard Nixon founded the EPA in 1970
and there was no parallel system of like
nice stuff and badges for good people
because you need a systemic solution and
so my biggest concern is that when they
put green labels or B Corps are on the
side thing there's nothing harmful in
and of itself and you can create uh
businesses that move in that direction
but never for a second can we be fooled
into believing that that's the solution
even if they want a market to sell doing
that because from a size perspective
look at the biggest B Corps and compare
them to the Fortune 500 and then wonder
how much time we have life like that's
not that's not the answer
so one more over here and then I have
one last question for you
go ahead hi my name is Henry I'm an
undergrad just to draw I guess attention
to the convergence initiative it was
created by a Stanford alumni and
represents the largest in total assets
under management at over 10 trillion
additionally with 260 General unlimited
Partners I guess my questions are the
six metrics they use are ghg emissions
renewable energy diversity work related
accidents net new hires and employee
again engagement do you what are your
thoughts on those metrics uh well first
of all I'm really impressed that this
this initiative has such a strong PR
behind it was sorry was it Stanford
linked I know a little bit about it but
it's PR it's private Equity specific
right yeah so she leads the um the ESG
she's the lead leader of ESG Calpers and
worked with Carlisle and BCG to publish
this
so I would say the same outside of other
things in general standardization uh and
better reporting is good
but not if we think that that's
sufficient that may be necessary as a
step but it's not sufficient and uh I
would love here here's a real question
for private private Equity industry I
would love for them to commit to
um both this Initiative for better
reporting for companies and then also in
the guise of responsible and fair
capitalism including you know for their
younger and more diverse employees also
disclose how they've used any kind of
political spending to influence debate
on the carried interest tax loophole
wouldn't that seem a fair thing I don't
listen I'm an ex-insider so I'm not a
socialist but I represent different a
different group in this in this so it's
this is just this is these are shared
economic problems and there needs to be
negotiation about them and I think
initiatives like this are good they're
smart people behind it and they know
very well that like this should be part
of a broader conversation in a democracy
so the last the last question one that
plays on something and not and I were
talking about earlier you mentioned
earlier we all agree with stakeholder
capitalism do we should we be aiming for
a world in which Milton Friedman is
actually right and corporations can just
focus on making money because government
can focus on setting the rules under
which corporations should make money and
if if that's right what would it take to
get to a world in which Milton Friedman
can be right
it can be uh Right In terms as well so I
guess it's almost two directions it
sounds odd but One Direction you know
you'd need to have enough regulations
that the government could actually
control
the private pursuit of profit in a way
that generally helps the public interest
and is more controlled obviously if you
have a slow-moving system responding to
regulatory tax needs as the US does
today you're not going to get
um that movement but in theory you could
go in that direction but that doesn't
change the need for wholesale change in
culture I don't actually the one thing I
think that is challenging of the Milton
Friedman model is the idea that you know
um
you should only try to squeeze money out
because if you combine that with
short-termism and capitalism and a set
of other things you end up a situation
that's really damaging
um my concern though is that when people
say we should depart the Milton Friedman
model they're right but you know if you
mean from a cultural perspective like it
took us 50 plus years to get here right
and we've built complex bureaucracies
that are squeezing profits out of every
last step I don't think you can undo
that with like changing the culture or
business you're going to need to do both
the regulatory push which moves kind of
towards Milton Friedman so you can just
focus on profits and let the referees
Marshal things
um but you also do need to change the
culture of the game they both need to
happen but mandatory compliance is the
key because you'll never get there as
fast as we need without that okay that
makes sense thank you all so much for
coming thank you for these really
insightful remarks I think we have a
long way to go from where we are but I'm
grateful to you for starting to raise
some of these really important questions
[Applause]
[Music]